c'est toujours leur de barbarie ça avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli ajouté gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
ah les deux sont intéressants alors le
shopping beinheim et là bas je lâche
tout lâche est ce qu'elles veulent à
beinheim ce fait sa garde-robe ces
petites jupes ses trucs et tout sexy
baby j'adorerais
où
on a obligé de choisir
l'australie avec booder ce que j'aime
bien les kangourous et je suis sûr qu'il
fera varier
je préfère la plage parce que j'ai vue
sur la mer et vers le sel marin n'ont
rien que ça ça en vaut la peine
et j'adore kelly kelly je voulais lui
dire les entends j'ai fait mes adieux à
tpm p
kelly est une vraiment je trouve qu'elle
a un visage mais angélique c'est une des
plus belles filles qui met vraiment je
dis sincèrement que j'ai croisé depuis
que je fais ce métier elle est adorable
salzbourg j'aime bien à get mais kelly
je la trouve tôt possible
[Musique]